yeah i was poor because i came to united
states and we lost everything but i was
the youngest employee in the federal
reserve bank at the age of 17.
you know i was an honor student i went
to school full time
and i worked at the photo server bank
full-time i went to school at the
university of miami full-time owned
scholarship
and i had i've never done drugs
didn't drink all the alcohol by the age
of 20 that i drank fit in a teacup that
size still today
no i i love my wine today okay so you
know i do yes she's validating that
exactly she's validating that
but
you know i i can tell you what i did for
four years every day of my life i got up
at 5 30 in the morning i was at the bank
at 6 30 i worked at 3 30. i got home at
four my mother had dinner i leave the
house at 4 30 4 45 i have my first class
you know
miami 5 30. i leave at 10 30. i go home
and i study till 2 30. i did that every
day for four years you so your mom
eventually came to miami yeah my mom
eventually joined us about
uh seven months later seven months yeah
so you were 11 years old when she came
to me
right before i turned 11 years old i was
still 10. so so so you're now uh you're
going to school you're an honor student
you're very uh systematic you have
discipline mom and dad have taught you
strong values
mindset of you're not poor mindset of
standing up for yourself don't be a weak
you're strong respectful all of these
things your parents have taught you so
your trajectory at this point is what
who is
jorge valdez going to end up being at
this point
i had a clear vision i would i would
graduate from miami at 20
i take a couple years to work save
enough money i go to law school at 22
23. i graduate from low school 25 and
i'll be a millionaire at 30 because if
i'm not a millionaire i'm a nobody
that's how you're seeing and that was my
whole world and nothing would deviate
from that i had a little girlfriend that
i would see very very seldom and if we
ever went ever we hardly even went to
party went to a party and i smelled pot
now remember this is the 70s which is
like probably like alcohol flowers yeah
i i don't know i gotta leave
i'm a fellow employee
i can't you know are you crazy
i got this view i didn't have a traffic
ticket i didn't have anything in my life
and uh
and that was the whole thing
and uh and then
so i'm gonna be a lawyer by 30
millionaires this is what i'm gonna i'm
gonna be a lawyer about 25 million or by
30 is what i'm going to do because if
i'm not that i'm nobody
okay so your identity sink or swim
that's it i'm not playing small i'm
going to go do something big and this is
a million 30 years old in what 70s like
early early 80s 76 26 okay yeah so so
okay so now what happens where you get
introduced to this life so i at 76 my
accounting professor
uh he had left from michigan it was a
partner president waterhouse came to
miami and this speaks spanish so he's
like hey george
if you come work for me and do my
spanish clients i'll give you secretary
office
everything to start your business and to
me that was like heaven opening up
because i wanted to be on my own i mean
i thought i had a heck of a future at
the federal reserve bank
me and the vice president of the federal
reserve bank office were the only two
that they paid tuition to go to
university of miami everybody else had
to go to state college
so
when he told me that my mother
my father very conservative you're crazy
stay with the bank you have a hell of a
future my mother you'll never be nobody
working for somebody
[Music]
so you know my mother was everything in
our house like most uh hispanic mothers
and uh and i resigned and i went to work
for him and the first client that he
gave me was a little grocery store in
miami like a little strip uh joint and
not a not a strip club strip joint
slightly different no a little
different you don't like those shopping
centers in miami right together i mean
like i don't know 10 feet 15 feet wide
40 feet uh deep
and
it was a little grocery store
and i go there monday i'm supposed to go
every monday
in the morning couple hours and pay me a
thousand dollars right there i'm gonna
be rich thousand dollars i mean i'm
making minimum wage is 85.95 i'm making
350 working for the bank i'm a big shot
you know
a thousand dollars for three hours i'm
mad so i go there and they have a little
office in the back
and i go and i see this paper sack
and he had like a hundred and some
thousand dollars
and i'm like wow i look around no way
this girl should still produce that i
thought well maybe they haven't made the
passes in a year i don't know
no clue
zero clue what's going on
do my accounting
go to the bank deposit the hundred
thousand dollars boom show up next week
seventy five
and i'm like
no there's gotta be something wrong
so the only thing i could think of
there's a shelf and i never forget it
had a a can of campbell's soup
and it was dusty it's been sitting there
for a long time so i'm gonna go and i'm
going to put a v on top of that can i
want to see if this can't sell because
i'm coming back next week and
now i'm like yeah
what a thing to do but think about this
now suspicious that something's going on
the least of them all if they give me a
hundred choices i would have showed
cocaine as the hundredth of the choices
got it oh what was going on remember now
how were they asked people just regular
people yeah just regular yeah regular
colombian uh pretty wild you know
everyone thought he got mad at the wife
so the wife gets out and gets a big old
piece of ham and throws it at him at the
store and he takes out his gun shoots
the ham and puts it back in the counter
i'm like oh these people a little
different than i am
you're 20 21 at this time i'm 20. okay
got it i'm 20. it's 1976. i just left
the bank
and uh
so
do my accounting go back
and the next week when i come there's
another time i'm like no i need
explanation and i never forget i called
him in there and said bro let me give
you a little accounting lesson
you see that kind of campbell soup
that's still there because i put a v on
it and
and he hasn't gotten nowhere to have the
v
well if that can is a dollar and you
sell it tomorrow for three dollars
you have generated three dollars worth
of income and two dollars worth of
profit
so here's the problem i've deposited
close to three hundred thousand dollars
and yet
the receipts for all you bought don't
add up to 1500 bucks
what gives
you think that they would like come up
with some
they looked at me and they're like oh
yeah this is nothing no we're drug
dealers they just told you i mean just
like that we're drug dealers
we sell cocaine now let me go back at
least they're honest about it yeah in
the 70s
in the 70s cocaine does not have the
stigma that cocaine has and should have
today right in the 70s it was for the
rich and famous the hollywood
celebrities i mean you could buy a
gorgeous house in miami four bedroom for
40 grand and a kilo cocaine was 60 to
70. so if you like this sort of short
clip from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]